how's it going everyone it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel
and mcu the future of marvel studios has
never looked brighter we got a lot of
new content released to us during
disney's investor day
including a little teaser from kevin
feige the head of marvel studios
about the fantastic four kevin feige
teased the fantastic four along with the
x-men at san diego comic-con of 2019
confirming that they are coming to the
mcu sooner than later
but now everybody is freaking out
because the fantastic four is actually
starting production
and you know what that means that means
that right now they are looking for or
they've possibly already found
a director a writer and of course the
cast and as far as casting is concerned
it looks like marvel fans might actually
get what we want
and most of you i'm sure know what i'm
talking about john krasinski as mr
fantastic
and emily blunt his wife as sue storm
the invisible woman
now when kevin feige gave us that little
teaser for the fantastic four during the
investor day presentation
he didn't really give us that much
information just a tiny bit
but we do have an estimated release date
for the fantastic four and that is in
2023 and this is based off of an
official report from disney where they
listed all of their new projects coming
and they listed the fantastic four
between 2022 and 2023 projects
so we can expect it to come in about two
two and a half to three years which is a
lot
sooner than i think a lot of the fandom
actually thought we were going to get
the fantastic four
now we have some pretty cool and
interesting news that's been happening
lately about the fantastic four but
first
let's go over what exactly kevin feige
said when he presented the fantastic
four
during the investor day and finally
i'm happy to announce a film about one
of the truly iconic marvel families
in fact marvel's first family fantastic
four
we're working on a feature now and it
will be directed by the director of our
recent spider-man films
john watts we've got a lot in store
marvel studios
and disney plus is key to the
interconnection and expansion of the mcu
now if you noticed he said that a
feature is in the works right now
confirming that things are underway
which means marvel probably already has
a cast or knows who they want to cast
for the roles and are working on casting
them now
and it is looking like it could be john
krasinski and
emily blunt playing the lovely couple of
mr fantastic and the invisible woman
but the actors who were in the running
to play the human torch the thing
and dr doom may be a little different
than you think
now the casting process for the
fantastic four has definitely already
begun
and this has been mentioned recently by
a few different sources such as grace
randolph and others
and of course the big question is who
exactly are going to play
these amazing characters the fantastic
four marvel's first
family well the vegas betting site
bovada has released odds on which actors
will play the four
lead heroes mr fantastic the invisible
woman the human torch and the thing
and the villain dr doom and we're going
to go over
each character and the odds of which
actor is most likely to play the
character
and we'll start it off with the one and
only reed richards aka mr fantastic
and as you can see here there are eight
actors they list here for having the
best
odds of landing the role as mr fantastic
and
john krasinski is at the head now i do
think john krasinski would make a very
good
mr fantastic especially if marvel
studios is going to want to mimic the
more
recent mr fantastic from the comics john
krasinski with a beard and
reed richards in the recent comics with
a beard look very
very similar to each other and the
characteristics of
the more recent mr fantastic from the
comics could match really well with some
characteristics from john krasinski
now most of these actors on here are
really great and i think all of them
would actually do a pretty good job
if they weren't going to cast john
krasinski i'd actually really love to
see ewan mcgregor but i think he's going
to be a little bit too busy filming the
kenobi series for star wars and after
him i think rahul kohli would make a
really good mr fantastic as well but
let's keep in mind
marvel studios has already been speaking
to john krasinski
and this is confirmed john krasinski met
with marvel studios via zoom during the
pandemic
but nobody really knows what he met with
them for or what they talked about
but given the fact that he is the top
choice to play mr fantastic in the
marvel cinematic universe we can bet
that that conversation
most likely came up and for those of you
who say that fan
casting doesn't work well disney did
that with ahsoka
disney did state that the reason they
cast rosario dawson
and the reason she was on their radar
was because of the fans fan casting her
so disney definitely does pay attention
to the fans and along with
jon meeting with marvel studios his wife
emily blunt has
also met with them she reportedly met
with them while filming jungle cruise
with the rock which is a disney property
and since disney owns marvel it was
probably pretty convenient to meet with
her
and we already know that marvel and
disney love emily blunt
they actually wanted her to be black
widow originally before scarlett
johansson
and now this website has emily blunt
listed as the top pick to play the
invisible woman
so the odds for the couple joining the
mcu as mr fantastic and the invisible
woman are looking pretty good although i
wouldn't mind a jessica chastain
sue storm also let's not forget that
john krasinski did
address the rumors and he said if they
are considering me for mr fantastic
continue to consider me because i would
love it now maybe marvel hasn't talked
to him but this is most likely him
playing coy because
we know that when actors are being
considered for roles and they've met
with studios
they don't talk about it perfect example
is tatiana men's lady it was reported
that she was going to be jennifer
walters
she-hulk but when asked about it after
the report she actually denied it but
then of course during the investor day a
few weeks ago it was confirmed that she
is indeed
going to be playing she-hulk so the fact
that jon said that is most likely him
playing coy
now moving on to the human torch in the
lead right now is actually anthony ramos
anthony starts and hamilton and the
upcoming movie in the heights
i think a lot of people were expecting
either daiquiri montgomery or zac
efron to be first but ephron is actually
second and daiquiri is
fifth but what's curious is that liam
hemsworth is actually in the running
right now and there was a rumor
a long time ago i'm talking like over a
year ago that stated that he was being
considered to play the human torch so
this could be more than a coincidence
and maybe marvel studios is considering
him to play the human torch
after all his brother is thor chris
hemsworth so he definitely has some
connections with marvel studios
andrew garfield is also listed on there
which is kind of interesting but i don't
think marvel studios would do that
because there would be some
confusion with the whole spider-man
character to some kids now as far as the
thing and
ben grimm are concerned the actors they
have on here are kind of what you would
expect
leading right now is steven graham and
dean norris who have the typical
white bald guy look from the original
fantastic four movie and then they have
people on the list
like john cena and the rock who are just
really really big guys but the thing is
ben grimm doesn't actually have to be
played by a big actor
mark ruffalo is not a big guy by any
means but they use cgi for the hulk and
they can do the same for the thing
ultimately most of it probably will be
mocap and cgi
so as long as the actor is a good actor
it probably doesn't matter too much
and then last but definitely not least
the odds for actors to play dr
doom and first on the list is giancarlo
esposito who
i actually really like for a pick the
only thing that i'm really worried about
is that he may be a little too old for
the role
but coming in second on this list is
silly and murphy who i think would make
a
very very excellent dr doom and nikolaj
coster waldo is on there as well and i
think he would do an excellent job as
well
but as this site has it right now the
actors with the best odds to play the
fantastic four
are john krasinski emily blunt anthony
ramos
stephen graham and guancarlo esposito
if these were the actors that are chosen
to play these roles
what would you think of the new
fantastic four let me know in the
comments and be sure to subscribe if you
want to stay up to date on all things
relating to the fantastic four in the
mcu
give the video a like if you enjoyed it
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
me
you